we've seen a number of racial hate
hoaxes over the years they've cropped up
we just got another one
clifton yutzy 18 years old just claimed
his bmw was vandalized in a hate crime
that the suv was sprained spray-painted
with racist slurs including
the n-word including the kkk
messages against black lives matter and
the minute i saw this story i said that
didn't happen
it didn't happen i know it didn't happen
because that
that is not the sort of thing that
happens as a rule in america
that is the sort of thing that the left
believes happens as a rule in america
that's why it's so easy to point these
out and it's why the left always falls
for these and the conservatives do not
well turns out i was right this was
perpetrated by the alleged victim
himself mr yutzi
uh he also put a message a pro donald
trump message on there
put sugar in his own gas tank that's too
bad it was insurance fraud
and erie county uh and uh this is
obviously uh
i believe this was in erie county
pennsylvania somewhere over there
they are now going to charge this guy
for lots of crimes as they should
because this sort of thing really really
rips up america and it is just a crime
in itself
to commit insurance fraud normal and
decent people
of all races not these radicals
and these race hustlers like this guy
you'd see were like the people in that
video
but normal the majority normal decent
people
of all races reject this stuff you
actually just saw it in california
california
tried to reinstitute racial quotas
racial biases in hiring to disadvantage
i guess whites whites and asians and to
give advantage to black and hispanic
applicants for various jobs and that
proposition failed it failed 57 to 43
percent
and it failed not just because white
people voted against it
not even in particular because white
people voted against it because racial
minorities voted against it
latinos in particular who would have
benefited from the
from the the program that's a good sign
and it reminds me clarence thomas said
this very same thing he wrote it in his
memoir
these kinds of quotas these kind of
programs this kind of what what michael
gerson called the
the soft biggest bigotry of low
expectations
these sorts of things do not just hurt
asians or white people or
even the country broadly they hurt the
people that they purport to help
because they damage their dignity
because they put them on an unequal
playing field
you know you hear this phrase no one's
equal until everybody's equal yeah well
okay sure if that's true it's certainly
true in this case as well
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts
you